dude if you watch wild wild country it's
the best holy [ __ ] okay when your one or
two episodes into that I'm four episodes
in look at perfect perfect so you can
get this how much of you thinks Oh
Duncan could start one of these a
thousand rights on peace and happiness
and [ __ ] wearing the same [ __ ] it's a
great dude I was talking like these
people seem cool I was talking to my
friend Todd and he was like dude I I
wanted to live like yeah man I wear red
who's like the first episodes of Sons of
Anarchy they seem like they're happy
they are happy they're having a good old
time
the Duplass brothers made that those
guys are bad uh yeah yeah that's an
amazing documentary it's [ __ ] it's right
the story is so insane while I'm
watching I'm like how the [ __ ] did I not
know I don't know about it it was so
good that I thought it was a work for a
while I was like I think they might be
faking this Oh God so I didn't see Tom
Brokaw talking about it you know all
right I guess I guess it happened I got
a friend mine and his girlfriend's
parents were in that group really yeah
and they still they still follow that
guy's teachings they still believe in
him the Mogwai osho osho his name was
they it wasn't Margaret's grandma this
is a picture that I had of him that I
put up on my Instagram page of him
holding this white guy's head and this
guy's like coming in his pants I was
like oh this up Jamie I love it he's
just play like you could have money you
can have nice things
yeah 22 [ __ ] Rolls Royce 22 roses look
at this oh look at the guy the guys like
oh I'm so white he's touching both of
them at the same time left handling the
dude right hand the girl he's like
transmitting through them brew they're
giving them orgasms look at him he's
like oh my god they believed in it man
we're all gonna [ __ ] go ahead go
ahead and piss the crazy have you seen
any of this Jamie I think I turned it on
and fell asleep and how dare you you
believe that [ __ ]
dude it's [ __ ] amazing man I'm I'm on
Episode four now and I don't want to
give anything away and in terms of like
how it goes down but it literally keeps
ramping up and getting more and more
[ __ ] insane I am like what Ari said I
can't believe I didn't hear about this
how do we know about Jonestown everybody
knows don't drink the kool-aid or was
this this is an Oregon outside of
Antelope Oregon dude I mean I don't want
to I can't give too much away but these
people bought a town they bought the
whole town they got a police force
do they have their own police force what
are the odds that something like that is
going on now it's super low it's super
low because what this is is they what
the government had stepped in and
realized that there's some shenanigans
going on and they were essentially there
was no separation of church and state
because the church was the state right
they had a government and police force
that was run by the church they called
it to peace force and the whole cult
basically ran the town except for a few
diehards who didn't want to give their
houses up so there were some folks who
had been living in Antelope their whole
life they didn't give their houses up
and they're telling the story and there
did not care for it it's [ __ ] amazing
man up so jealousy of having not seen
the whole sex cult and there's another
one right this is a different ones one
with the actress that got yeah Hilary so
that's is that's a similar type cult
things that deal with had actress I
don't know that you really recruit
people knowing it was a sex cult I don't
know if that's the same thing right not
as many people I don't know much about
this sex cult thing with that actresses
I'm not getting the whole story branding
they were branding people but she was
she was a part of it she was recruiting
people and take allegedly this is what
they're charging her with I feel like
there's more to the story than I can
tell I don't know man but it's weird
that people are so susceptible to cults
and that we protect people from cults
but don't protect people from religions
it's the same sure the only difference
is this one guy is banging all these
people and we got to stop that boils
under that appears there was sex crimes
there was like tongue trafficking and
there was there was there was illegal
things that we're done in this
particular one from what I've read I
don't know too much about it but then
go to that Osho guy and awesome legal it
seemed except for church and state see
the thing is the church started running
the police force alright remember and
they had these guys walking around with
[ __ ] you know semi-automatic rifles
and high-powered machine guns and [ __ ]
it was very different it's like okay
you've got a military force that's
guarding this religious lives out of
that yeah so they have these police
people at the compound in the hallways
with machine guns these guys are playing
assassin and they they are the police
force they're not they're not private
exactly what's the call group I don't
give anymore away I just watch
everything I've said is not gonna take
anything away from sure with the
girlfriend your boyfriend your wife or
whatever who you need with somebody
together let's just like find somebody
like let's watch it one episode every
two days let's talk about it alright so
fun I think an independent version of
that is in little blips what goes on
with Burning Man like this independent
little blip of escape of norms of
regular society and these people get
there they wear [ __ ] gas masks and
[ __ ] each other and go crazy and do
cartwheels in the dirt and they hang out
together for having a great time and
they realize that people can at least in
small bursts can establish these
communities set up all this temporary
art have a great time and everybody's
like you know really like like-minded in
other ways I'm going out in this one
place well if that's if people want that
the only difference between that and
like a full-time community is that you
would have to figure out a way to get
everybody to get along forever okay just
be a few days you'd have two great kids
together get your food together do it
the fook have other jobs you have
keyboards is a similar to that yeah but
if you try to do that today they would
stop you or at least it would become a
real issue like say if you decided you
and Duncan got together and you two
decided by 700 acres in Oregon and you
found some place you could all Ford you
did a Kickstarter and you guys set up a
community out there you grew your own
food you had your own well in every room
nobody could be married and you could
[ __ ] anybody you want this is how we
live in okay that's how we live in and
then you just you just rent and you like
real loosely based rules hey when you
eat something clean up your mess
giant mess halls filled with people
people of these houses all over this
[ __ ] ranch and you you basically
established a village Wow
you just can't go too far yeah but then
you start getting money from them mmm
when someone breaks the real law like
there's a rape or murder you'd have to
be like now we need to call them yeah
you have to cops
the only way to keep its own heart so do
that yeah you'd have to keep it legit
yeah like you'd have to still be on this
jurisdiction you'd have to make friends
with the local sheriffs mmm yeah just
like we're not we don't mean any harm
but when yeah when we need you when
something happens we'll call you but
yeah otherwise we're not gonna need your
much yeah we're just go up here banging
each other ha yeah just I think staying
at each other like crazy it's getting
[ __ ] wild up here son that's what we
do it's legal right still leave it a
[ __ ] in America if I pay taxes yeah so
my my my best buddy's wife can slam my
ball ass [ __ ] him yes like okay that
girl she likes to suck ball right next
to the booty hole I think you'd run into
problems people would decide that you
shouldn't be living like that they don't
want people that's with everything it's
with everything you're not living the
way I live so I'm not gonna let anyone
be into your [ __ ] yeah but it's always
like one dude right that's running
things in power I'm one of those yes
compounds and there's always like a main
guy who [ __ ] everybody [ __ ]
everybody's wife it's like [ __ ]
everybody want but you probably wanna
[ __ ] me on the main there it's the only
way to do it honestly is to do at
Burning Man style this is my point is
that Burning Man style would be no
leader no leader yeah no leader so
like-minded people no leader and you'd
have two feet but the problem is
charismatic people could co-op that
you'd have these meetings one person
takes over look what we need here some
organization next you know he's the king
yeah you know that's how people do or
monkeys yeah if we could avoid that no
your crave leader yeah yeah we'd have to
somehow or another find a way to not
manipulate the way laws are they yeah
they're not those sex cults but they are
like everyone has a job we're all
working for nobody makes money or
everybody makes 20 bucks a week whatever
it is you know room and board is paid
for and that makes people feel really
good yeah you're all doing an equal part
yeah you one guy could be running the
accounting for the thing one guy could
be you know taking eggs you know one
person takes
the nursery of the kids but like
everyone joins that